Good morning, John. Today I discovered that
people don't look at you funny if you’re
in an airport vlogging and you're talking
on the phone at the same time, so I’m just
going to pretend like we’re talking on the
phone.
This isn’t actually my video for today;
I’m actually making a pre-made video because
I want to talk about a new thing that we are
going to be doing. See, YouTube has decided
to let us into the little livestreaming party,
and so we are going to join them and start
doing livestreams. And we’re going to start
that today. Today is the official launch of
YouTube.com/live, which is where you will
be able to find YouTube livestreams, and John
and I are going to be doing that, and I am
very excited. John is doing a show today from
2:30 to 4:30 Eastern time. I think that you
should come, and whoever’s on the phone,
on the other end of the phone, I think they
should come too.
In these livestreams, John and I are going
to be talking about, ah, you know, well, nerdy
things. John’s gonna read nineteenth century
poetry and I’m gonna talk about theoretical
physics, and we’re gonna browse Reddit together,
and we’re gonna read books and play songs,
and it’s gonna be fun! So, check out John’s
livestream, 2:30 to 4:30, at youtube.com/vlogbrothers,
which is our YouTube channel, and we will
be doing more of them in the future. I hope
that you enjoy them!
John, you will see me later today.